اذا وتحدثنا عن الاسلحه التكنولوجيه
الحديثه غير المستخدمه بشكل فعال في الحرب
لكن ماذا سيكون شكل الحروب في المستقبل
سناخذكم في جوله
نحن في عام 2050 بالنسبه لواشنطن التهديد
الاكبر بات الحرب الالكترونيه ولم يعد
الحرب التقليديه او الحرب النوويه نعم الا
يمكننا تحديد شكل الميادين القتال
المستقبل لكن بالنظر لنجاحات المسيرات في
اكثر من حرب واخرها اوكرانيا تطور الجيوش
تطور الجيوش الكبرى منها وتطور مدرعات
وطائرات مقاتله غير ماهوله بل ان الطائرات
قد تزيح المركبات المقبوله بالشكل كامل
بحلول منتصف القرن الجاري سلاح جديد قد
يغيره قواعد الاشتباك نظام الدفاع
الامريكي بالليزر سيفعل ما لم يفعله اي
نظام سلاح الليزر كهربائي ارضي من قبل هذا
ما صاروخين
من الصواريخ وعلى عكس الانظمه الحركيه
التقليديه مثل المدفعيه فهذا النظام لا
ينفذ الرصاص وابدا اما الجندي الخارق الذي
نراه في افلام يهوليود قد نراه كجزء من
محوري من الجيش الامريكي بحلول عام 2050
بحسب البنتاجون المميزات كثيره لكن منها
القدره السمعيه الهامه للغايه في ساحه
القتال جنود اليوم يرتدون حمايه اذن
لالغاء الضوضاء لفحص معدات ولوازم الاسلحه
وحمايه الاذن النسبيه حيث يعاني تعرض
وتعرض الكثير منها وستكون سماعات الراس
الصغيره مفيده للغايه اما جنود المستقبل
سيمتلكون نطاق اكبر من السمع والحمايه من
فقدان السمع النقطه الاكثر اثاره هي
الترابط العقلي العصبي للافكار بين جنود
الجيش الواحد ما يتيح مشاركه المعلومات
بشكل فوري لمساعده انظمه الكمبيوتر
والمسرات المسؤوله عن جمع المعلومات